hello hello and congratulations
thank you so much so to start here what
advice would you give to someone like me
who does not have a jazz in their life
and is convinced they can't dance for
[ __ ]
grab to encourage me to pull it off if
you want to you can
dance i've seen it happen right you know
it's it's a real thing to be perfectly
honest with you don't even need legs to
do it
there there's a beautiful scene in this
film actually where you get to see
um a group of dancers with what people
would
you know widely considered disabilities
uh
it becomes their superpower and they're
able to do things with their body that
like i
i have two perfectly working legs and
i've been dancing for a very long time
still could never do you know it's an
incredible thing i think that ultimately
it's a matter of if you want to or not i
think there are a lot of people that are
like oh i can't dance but
it's probably because you don't really
want to you don't have any desire to
learn and if you do have a desire to
learn it's just a matter of like
putting the work in putting the time in
that is a very very
fair point that i'm going to take to
heart okay so i know you are a
very talented dancer actor singer you
name
it but is there any skill over the
course of your career if not your life
that you know you wanted to learn you
thought you could never do it
and then you somehow pulled it off you
know i have a
habit of putting on new hats all the
time and and
you know if there's something that i
have wanted to figure out or learn how
to do
i i if i love it this is just kind of
how i'm wired i don't have an
addictive personality but i have an
obsessive one and
if there's something that i'm like oh i
really really like this
this is really exciting for me i zone in
and i'm a hundred and ten percent into
that thing i started like you know i
was probably five years ago i i decided
that i loved
wine to the point where i wanted to
learn about it and now like i've been
studying it and they want to become a
sommelier and open a restaurant at some
point in time like that's
that's just how i'm wired you know what
i mean um i think that
one of my actually you know if i had a
genie and i had three wishes one of my
wishes would be that i was fluent in
every language
in the world that's uh that would
probably be like the biggest thing for
me
and that really just requires the time
and putting the time and energy into it
um like i i i i
know enough of a few languages to be
able to kind of get around
and bubble my way through town but i i'm
not fluent in anything but
english and sarcasm so i i would love to
love to do that for sure i feel you on
that and this gives me an opportunity to
do a shameless plug for netflix you got
to go watch uncorked
oh oh yeah i mean listen song uncorked
all of it all of it i just i'm i'm just
ingesting it as much as i possibly can
so kind of on the flip side of that idea
jake in the movie is in a position where
his mentality is
if i can't be the absolute best at it
then forget it i'm just
not going to do it have you ever been in
that kind of position where you can
relate to that mentality uh no because
like i
i work i work the opposite way if
there's something that i really want to
do
and i'm not the best at it i don't stop
doing it
until i feel like i'm accomplished in it
you know um it's part of being a three
on the enneagram scale
i think um it could either be your your
your your biggest strength or your
biggest weakness
is uh just kind of zoning in and
and and tunnel visioning something
until you know you are red in the face
and uh that's kind of how i that's
that's kind of how i work but i think
that jake
you know jake worked really really hard
at something that he loved and then due
to a curveball that life threw at him
with his knee
you know all of that kind of went away
and his passion seemingly evaporated
right in front of him
and how he navigates that i think is in
large part due to the lack of people in
his life that
really encouraged him and inspired him
to keep going at it you know to recover
from this thing and
to pull yourself out of the ditch that
you have managed
to find yourself in and and uh quinn and
jazz and the rest of the rag tag team of
dancers that they pull together
help help him through that and help him
do that and he fuels that you know and
to watch that happen in real time i
think is a beautiful reflection on
humanity in general you know
who who's your biggest personal
cheerleader
uh my mom probably my mom is
she's just she i mean from the day i was
born she's just
anything that i've wanted to do that
i've set my except my my sights on
she's just been right there screaming
for me and
uh helping me in whatever way she can i
guarantee you my mom will be the first
one to like and share this
interview so i totally get where you're
coming from on that
so you've kind of proven you could do it
all
but when you're on the set of something
like a feature film
like work it what is the part of the
feature film production
process that you still find the most
challenging is it you know
big ensemble scenes one-on-one dialogue
is it the dance sequences you name it
it absolutely depends on the you know
just kind of the chemical balance of the
people that are on set
and what it is that you're tackling that
day uh there are certain
sequences and in terms of shot sequences
that can be you know remarkably
challenging due to just kind of like
pacing
tempo the amount of dialogue that has to
get done in one shot
um you know whatever the case may be it
absolutely depends on the chemical
balance
of the people that are involved and what
it is that you're tackling which is why
i love production so much it's why i'm
i definitely a handful of years ago
found a knack
for just problem solving on set and
trying to make things
trying to make something the best that
he can possibly be and in the most
efficient way possible the thing that
like you know
uh what whatever that centerpiece is for
the challenge of that day
and how to navigate it has always been
something that i love to do and it's
always been something that i
kind of yearn for to be honest with you
um i say that the hardest days on set
usually result in the best content
i could talk about behind the scenes
stuff all day long but you are talking
right now
to a new hamilton fan because i let
myself
experience it until i could see it in
full and thankfully that happened
recently so
what what is it like for you or what was
it like taking over a role in one of the
biggest
broadway shows of all time are you in a
situation where anthony ramos has to
like
give you some advice before you fully
judge yeah you know what's funny
it rarely happens to be honest with you
like it
it just rarely happens unless somebody
specifically comes to you and is like
hey can you give me some advice on like
the thing
it's usually just like being led by
example
um that is always like the biggest
takeaway that you
that you can muster from that kind of
scenario
and is one of the most talented people
in the world
um in all ways as an actor as a writer
as a creative he's remarkable and really
just like
you know especially in learning a role
on broadway you you know you're in
rehearsal space by yourself
all day you know with like an associate
choreographer an associate director
music director whatever and then
you're at theater in the evening and
you're watching the show or you are
trailing the person that you are
replacing backstage so you're basically
just like following them all around
backstage seeing what their routes are
their timing how long they stay here how
long they go here how much time they
have in between this
net blah blah blah blah blah blah and um
and it's just perfect
in that way because he's just he's so
chill and fun
and like just he's like yo homie hey so
let let's go over here real quick you
know and that's like
that that's that's what you need
especially in taking something on like
that you know this was
this was at the height of its popularity
when i joined the show
it was you know still like a concert
energy every night and the night that i
went on
um the other two guys that covered my
role both happened to be on stage that
night as well in different roles ant was
in la
so at that point i was the only person
in new york city
that could play the role and that you
have to just kind of thrust yourself on
stage and just do it because you don't
have another option you know
they just threw you into the deep end on
that and that's what and that's what you
have to do that's what you have to do
you know
thank you so much for your time today
and huge congratulations on working it's
a lot of fun i'm going to watch with my
little cousin this weekend
next week